et bien non le team n'est pas mort elvis
est vivant la preuve le voici sur scène
à bercy en chair et en os
en chair et en os ou presque le double
sur le podium ce sont bien les vrais
musiciens d'elvis ceux qui
l'accompagnaient à la fin de sa vie mais
les images sur l'écran sont en fait
vieille de 30 ans l'époque des grands
shows du king nous avons repris les
embauches au monde glisse et nous avons
isolé savoie sur scène les musiciens
jouent avec lui comme s'il était là et
le son est vraiment comme à l'origine
c'est vraiment incroyable
dans la salle la plupart des spectateurs
n'ont jamais vu le king de son vivant
mais le charme opère tout de même et à
tout âge
c'est le cas pour marie 93 ans et fan
d'elvis en 68 par exemple il était
magnifique
c'était un très très bel homme c'est
agréable de regarder un beau garçon sur
scène c'est magnifique de voir un ballon
qu'il a tenus c'est plus maintenant
maintenant on s'habille plus aussi bien
sur scène alors on avait tous on avait
l'homme on avait la tenue on avait la
voix
c'était magnifique
et quand on aime tant elle vise peu
importe après tout deneux l'applaudir
que virtuellement les vraies stars ne
meurent jamais